il est donc essentiel d'apporter la
sécurité juridique nécessaire pour
informer et valoriser les vignobles de
france
l'autorité war et le paysage quand on
parle de 20 ans parle pas d'alcool il a
quand même un point qui est un peu
difficile à entendre couple elle voulait
mais ça fait longtemps
souvenez vous en 2015 le sénat a
assoupli la loi evin en adoptant un
amendement polémique
son but ouvrir la porte à la publicité
indirecte pour l'alcool dans les médias
les opposants dénoncent un coup de force
du lobby du vin un an plus tard lors
d'un colloque au sénat de l'association
des élus de la ville on se réjouit des
facilités que cet amendement à porte
pour défendre les intérêts du monde
viticole
le marché bruisse parce que on dit des
lobbys qu'ils sont omniprésents
puissants et qu'ils arrivent même à
faire changer les lois
bien sûr je suis d'accord pour dire que
je vais juste puisque c'est la réalité
pour la vie presque au quotidien
le lobby n'est pas un gros mot à
condition de ne pas utiliser les ses
utilités ce terme de manière
nécessairement péjoratif
ce qui serait malsain on le voit très
bien ce serait qu'il y ait des
influences souterraines qui sont ils
vraiment comment travaille-t-il nous
allons tenter de vous faire découvrir
comment les groupes d'intérêts influence
le travail législatif
rue de varenne à paris à deux pas de
l'hôtel matignon en plein coeur du
quartier des ministères
un cabinet de lobbying idéalement situé
oui on pèse dans le débat public dans le
débat politique et en influence et on se
bat pour ça et quant au parlement
n'arrive pas à ses influences et on se
bat dans les médias pour qu'on puisse
influencer les parlementaires et on a un
seul objectif c'est gagné
lobbyiste depuis 30 ans thierry costes
oeuvre pour les intérêts des chasseurs
et il assume de vouloir influencer les
textes de loi sur son bureau parmi ces
documents de travail figure la liste des
élus présents en séance
classés par département avec la position
de chacun on fait des tableaux avec qui
étaient là ont fait des tableaux plus
fin avec qui était présent et a voté
quoi notamment côté des scrutins publics
donc ça on trace soyez les gens qui
étaient là un jour 2 jours 3 jours en
fonction des enjeux qu'il y avait sur la
chasse parce que parce que les
parlementaires peuvent parfois avoir
envie de dire j'étais là il n'était pas
mais en fiche les gens donc non non on
fait des tableaux de synthèse c'est pour
nous c'est c'est le sait le conducteur
c'est notre c'est notre fil conducteur
quand on bâtit une stratégie il faut pas
se perdre dans
dans la diffusion de toi tout le monde
parce que ça lasse tout le monde
les parlementaires reçoivent des
centaines de mails il a envoyé aux
parlementaires une version remaniée du
projet de loi biodiversité avec les
propositions d'amendement de la
fédération nationale de la chasse on
contacte les sénateurs qui seront
influents qui débattront du texte parce
qu'ils sont à la bonne commission la
commission environnement et qu'ensuite
ils seront en séance mais on convainc
aussi les chefs de groupe
les présidents de groupe on va parfois
même jusqu'à convaincre le président du
sénat on est très interactif c'est à
dire que on connaît bien les
parlementaires je les côtoie depuis
longtemps je les fréquente beaucoup pas
seulement situations d'urgence vous
pouvez va demander aux gens de vous
aider si vous ne les voyez qu à ce
moment là
et pour convaincre rien de mieux que le
contact direct le parlement pour un
lobbyiste est un lieu stratégique
thierry costes il passe pas mal de temps
ce jour là il a rendez vous au sénat
pour discuter chasse et biodiversité
à force de côtoyer des parlementaires
quand même on en a des relations de
confiance et de ses pratiques
ce bureau il le connaît bien c'est celui
de françois patriat sénateur ancien
député et ancien ministre de
l'agriculture doit maintenant dire
bonjour
samedi un jour bonjour exemple très bien
nous étions nous étions inquiets
pourquoi tu étais tout groupe à la
france était séquestré le groupe
j'écoute les deux hommes sont proches il
leur arrive même de chasser ensemble
thierry costes est venu lui expliquer
pourquoi il faut retoqué les articles
anti chasse a levé ce jeu qui viens vous
parler par exemple de la chasse dans les
territoires ruraux en france nous en
parlera des différents mandats
conseiller technique
moi j'aime bien travailler avec des deux
pianistes parce que je pense que les
conseillers en communication sont
souvent beaucoup moins pertinent dans la
perception des choses
albis c'est pas ce que quelqu'un qui
vient faire pression sur vous c'est
quelqu'un qui vous donne des éléments de
jugement
entretenir un dialogue permanent serait
donc la clé pour être persuasif
le jour du vote sur le texte
biodiversité
thierry costes est présent au sénat
salle des conférences en terrain connu
il retrouve le sénateur jean-noël
cardoux président du groupe d'étude sur
la chasse
tu m'as bien comment tu vas nicole 7
things we et c'est gênant situé 8 mai
avec un gage et c'est un horrible 17 h m
et moi je le suis infirmière il ya monté
au créneau de parlementaires de gauche
et de droite et des votes qui sont qui
sont pas politiques sont sauvés la
chasse en france un peu comme les
fromages prendre en compte les
territoires ruraux et ses enjeux un
argument de poids au sénat et ce n'est
pas le président du groupe chasse qui
dira le contraire
groupe d'étude le plus important avec
plus de 80 membres
on n'a pas pesé en acompte reposée
pourquoi on a été d'être actif parce que
l assemblée nationale d des attaques
la très virulente inattendus ont vu deux
jours contre certaines formes de chasse
et à partir de là
le monde de la chasse a été très très
fortement mobilisés et le groupe chasse
du sénat était le vecteur de cette
mobilisation et nous avons pu réussir à
supprimer ces ces amendements ces
attaques
les sénateurs ont réussi à sauver la
chasse à la glu une technique ancestrale
pratiquée dans plusieurs départements en
france l'électorat chasse pêche
représente près de 3 millions de
personnes
vous savez ça fait 30 ans que qu'est-ce
que je suis car en tant que le gravitent
dans le monde de la chasse a fait trente
ans que je connais ce monsieur on s'est
fréquenté la plupart de ceux que j'ai
retrouvé dans le milieu de la chasse
quand j'étais élu une présidence du
gonflage déconner ça depuis très
longtemps une autre connaissance de
longue date
le rapporteur de la loi biodiversité au
sénat
thierry costes le connais bien il a été
l'assistant parlementaire de jérôme
bignon quand il était député
ses représentants
c'est bon parce que sinon c'est
politiquement compte des excuses et les
annonces du plaisir mais mais sinon
c'est long je pense parce que
politiquement si tu ne prends pas
instituer reste pas sur cette ligne avec
moi je suis ministre
demain à l'assemblée jeudi voyez c'est
ça il était ma vision était presque
atteint quand c'est apparu on disait
presque comme les organisations
professionnelles aussi font du lobbying
à la fnsea influencer le contenu d'une
loi est un travail de tous les instants
des propositions d'amendements et des
argumentaires sont envoyés pour chaque
article
ensuite le plus dur reste à faire
s'assurer que le message est bien passé
lorsque les débats ont lieu
eh bien on a des tableaux de suivi
amendement par amendement qui le portent
qui défend quoi est-ce que nous sommes
favorables ou pas favorite est ce qu'il
a été adopté ou pas adopté ce qui nous
permet de faire me permet de faire un
suivi au jour le jour
un loyer quand césaire il n'y a pas de
souci quand ces roses attention et quand
c'est rouge c'est un c'est un vrai sujet
lorsqu'un par le moteur intervient et
que son argumentation nous paraît
insuffisamment appropriée c'est
certainement parce qu'on n'a pas fourni
suffisamment d'éléments et bien on est
en contact avec lui soit directement
soit indirectement on est on est très
transparent
tant que c'est pas sifflé c'est pas
gagné mais tant que ces passifs et s'est
pas perdu non plus donc jusqu'au bout il
faut travailler sur ces textes là et
pour influencer jusqu'à la dernière
minute un coup de fil peut s'avérer
efficace oui bonsoir c'est christiane
lambert je vous appelle à propos du
passage de la loi pour la dernière
lecture à l'assemblée et un amendement
auquel nous sommes très attachés
donc je ne sais pas qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire passer comme message pour
essayer d'amadouer un peu ou d'atténuer
la portée de ces
ces éléments là en tout cas c'est une
demande forte de la de la profession je
suis à votre disposition si vous voulez
me rappelais n'hésitez pas merci votre
écoute au revoir nous sommes très
sollicités la pression se fait par le
rappel au téléphone par des courriers je
trouve que le plus ignoble et moi ce
même si c'était une bonne cote
j'hésiterais à les soutenir dans des
conditions pareilles
c'est le petit paragraphe qui dit nous
sommes présents dans votre région nous
connaissons vos électeurs est votre
position sur ce sujet sera publié dans
les médias qui est un enjeu électoral et
je pense que si on limitait la
reconduction des mandats dans le temps
les parlementaires seraient plus
indépendants plus courageux puisqu'il ne
serait pas toujours en précarité est en
campagne électorale pour leur futur
mandat il arrive même aux parlementaires
de recevoir des amendements prêts à
imprimer comme celui ci ne manque plus
qu'à rajouter le nom de l'élu la date
est le numéro d'un moment ça se
reconnaît dans l'hémicycle pendant les
débats quand vous vous apercevez que des
groupes qui sont apparemment
contradictoires politiquement dépose à
droite et à gauche
exactement le même amendement dans les
mêmes termes avec le même exposé des
motifs la immédiatement un petit feu
rouge de vigilance c'est clair on sait
que c'est un lobby qui l'écrit c'est
donc une réalité
les groupes de pression tente de mâcher
le travail des parlementaires et
fournissent du clé en main
ce féru d'informatique va nous le
montrer il a créé avec d'autres membres
du collectif regards citoyens un
algorithme de plagiat on a pris des
documents de travail des lobbystes que
vous avez fourni et on l'a mis dans
notre moteur de recherche
à droite les amendements proposés par le
lobby de la chasse sur la loi
biodiversité à gauche ceux déposés par
les parlementaires résultats du copier
coller à la virgule près c'est un
amendement provenant du sénateur patriat
dans lequel est bien on voit que mot
pour mot même si la la la présentation
est un peu différente
c'est exactement le même amendement ça
on le voit du sénateur patriat du
sénateur hervé qu'internet terre
centriste et du sénateur navarro qui a
un sénateur non inscrit et là
strictement les trois amendements sont
sont identiques
ça a créé dit totalement la thèse que le
lobby de la chasse se repose sur des
parlementaires qui sont proches de lui
en tout cas qu'ils aient rôle est de
manière assez systématique ses opinions
dans le débat parlementaire et qui se
déroulait trans couvre qui sont des
relais transcourants absolument c'est ça
qui est sans doute ça qui fait la
spécificité de
des lobbys très influent c'est d'être
capable de porter des dispositions aussi
bien à droite qu'à gauche
et du côté du lobby agricole même
verdict du logiciel des morceaux de
texte identique
c'est le sénateur la serre et sur une
disposition assez similaire on a le
sénateur bizet qui paraît y dépose des
dispositions qui sont quasiment
similaires à celles du lobby agricole de
la fnsea on a vraiment l'impression que
il travaille malin de main dans la main
le travail qu'on a fait émerger des
sénateurs qui travaillent avec des
lobbys qui sont beaucoup plage et donc
c'est la fnsea et les chasseurs là où le
collectif des ong sont plutôt des
sources d'inspiration
que un copier coller du brutal
sénateur depuis 20 ans jean bizet défend
les positions du monde agricole
j'assume être du côté de ceux qui ont un
argumentaire j'assume être du côté des
socioprofessionnels parce que ce sont
eux les créateurs de richesse il s'est
opposé à l'interdiction totale des
néonicotinoïdes prévue dans le projet de
loi biodiversité et reçu des centaines
de mails des mails des ong de citoyens
parfois des mails de menaces pour tenter
de le faire changer d'avis et cette
affiche et les celles ci on en a tous
reçu sénateurs tueur d'abeilles
nous avons retrouvé les assassins voilà
voilà dans quelle société nous vivons
nous ne sommes plus dans un état de
droit se débattre mon avis et est à la
fois surréaliste extrêmement dangereux
parce qu'en fin de compte on à légiférer
sous le poids de l'émotion et de
l'intimidation a été orchestrée par ces
ong pendant de nombreuses années
élargir le cercle de l' expertise à la
société civile faire de tout citoyen des
décideurs en matière environnementale au
dessus de la représentation nationale
c'était l'archi tout simplement le
cercle de l'arbitraire on en est là à
mon avis il faudra revenir si vous
voulez quand on viendra en
responsabilité à une architecture
beaucoup plus rationnelle
pas question d'y mettre les ong ou les
associations
il y aurait donc selon le sénateur des
groupes de pression plus légitime que
d'autres
générations futures a été très active
lors des débats sur la loi biodiversité
l'association qui travaille sur les
dangers des pesticides a défendu
l'interdiction des néonicotinoïdes
dangereux pour les abeilles elles aussi
tentent d'influencer la loire et ne s'en
cache pas un même argumentaire a été
envoyée aux parlementaires de tous bords
c'est normal que les parlementaires
écoute plus les parties prenantes mais
c'est pas normal c'est que importe de
force entre les ong à l'industrie qui
accorde à 520000 et on n'a pas une force
de frappe du tout de même nature que les
intérêts industriels
on en n'est pas non plus aussi inclus
dans les rouages je pense en parlant de
ça au lobby agricole sa qui sont
tellement partout que finalement les
instants de lobbying sont permanents les
thèses mais demande du syndicat afe les
soeurs sont répétés tous les moments de
la journée dans des élus qui vont à
statuer après son enterrement soumis à
ce rouleau compresseur idéologique alors
que nous pour pouvoir toucher un député
faucon demande un rendez-vous on l'a on
l'a pas nous on considère que c'est
normal qu au sénat dans tous les lieux
de l'expression démocratique des
décisions ont la possibilité d'avoir une
expression de toutes les parties
prenantes mais elle devrait être sur un
pied d'égalité
c'est très bête malheureusement ce n'est
pas le cas l'exercice d'un flux ans n'a
pas lieu contre les murs du parlement
no - de l'assemblée nationale la maison
de la chimie est désormais l'un des
hauts lieux de l'organisation de
colloques parlementaire une pratique de
lobbying moins connus mais qui se
développe depuis de nombreuses années
des rencontres sur un thème qui réunit
hommes politiques monde de l'entreprise
et de la société civile
conseils vous êtes malade et ses élus au
premier rang directement interpellé ces
colloques permettent aux lobbyistes de
tous rangs d'avoir un accès direct à
ceux qui votent les lois d'entretenir de
bonnes relations
c'est ce que confirme l'organisateur ni
si des parlementaires des ministres des
gens qui ont le pouvoir de faire bouger
les choses pour qu'ils se disent bah
tiens c'est pas mal on pourrait appeler
faire quelque chose
c'est bien sûr alors c'est ce qu'on
appelle le lobbying et c'est ce qui fait
très peur parce que ça rapporte
évidemment toute la question est de
savoir si le lobbying c'est prendre
quelque chose qu'on nous donne le
traduire sans réfléchir et reprendre
l'amendement en copier coller ou si
c'est la question du libre arbitre que
nous avons
les habitués ont surnommés ces
rencontres l'antichambre du dépôt
d'amendements en commission c'est aussi
l'occasion d'échanger adresse et cartes
de visite
et puis parfois un déjeuner ça continue
autour comptable voilà et je pense que
c'est très bien pour alimenter la
réflexion des milieux parlementaires
il serait déjà arrivé lors de telles
rencontres que les financeurs privés qui
paye le plus et le temps de parole le
plus long mais comment dans ces cas là
gardée des débats objectif
en pratique derrière ces colloques sont
présentes plusieurs agences de lobbying
la première d'entre elles est mnm
conseil dont les locaux sont situés
juste en face de la maison de la chimie
son dirigeant pascal talent on nous
confirme que l'organisation de ces
colloques coûte cher qu'il faut trouver
des financements un intervenant peut
débourser entre 8000 et 20000 euros pour
le public c'est gratuit en fait le
financement et l'intervention sont pas
liés il ya des gens qui interviennent
mais qui ne financent pas les gens qui
financent mais qu'ils n'interviennent
pas c'est s'est pas laissée pas il n'y a
pas un lien entre les deux sur une
matinée vous avez 20 intervenants il y
en a 4 5 qui ont financé et pas plus oui
mais sinon ce bienheureux ci avait 20 un
financeur maman s'appelle carte
le cabinet organise plusieurs colloques
par mois dont la plupart sont à
l'initiative de parlementaires
généralement quand il ya une initiative
elle nous vient d'un élu c'est rare
qu'il y ait un binôme droit du gauche
qui se soit fait naturellement par
lui-même donc nous on lui dit bon c'est
bien mais il faudrait aussi un autre de
l'autre camp et que vous fassiez
ensemble parce que
notre souhait n'est pas d'organiser des
initiatives partisane et d'autre part
nous notre charte est une charte qui
dictent toutes les organisations qu'on
fait doivent être plus réaliste
autres méthodes de lobbying très prisé
celle des clubs parlementaire apparu
dans les années 90 il en existe une
quarantaine la sénatrice marie noëlle
lienemann préside le club de l'accession
à la propriété
elle assure que l'expertisé apportée par
ces clubs est nécessaire pour bien
légiférer
à l'heure où de plus en plus de textes
sont examiné en procédure d'urgence
j'écoute les arguments des autres ni
blocage quand quand on fait des lois qui
sont tatillons qui sont mal adaptés au
terrain parce qu'on a aussi beaucoup à
veiller à ce que les textes de lois
soient opérationnelles atteignent
l'objectif qu'on a voulu comme parlement
a voulu fixer club des amis du cochon
club chiens et société observatoire de
l'oeuf des intitulés à première vue
fantaisistes quelques uns sont tellement
spécialisées qu'il est difficile de ne
pas y voir derrière les porte-voix
d'intérêts privés les rencontres
organisées par les clubs sont un lieu
privilégié pour mettre en relation
parlementaire et groupes de pression de
manière légale certes mais aussi très
opaque jeunes gens
merci françois merci infiniment à
bientôt ce lobbyiste a créé 15 clubs de
sa propre initiative au revoir
travailler c'est lui qui demande aux
élus de l'est présidé avec le souci à
chaque fois qu'il y ait un élu de droite
et un de gauche il considère que ce en
acceptant cette président s'est montré
que le sujet qui est porté par le club
les intéresse ils sont totalement
disponible pour écouter les
professionnels que l'on va mettre autour
d'une table davantage pour des
parlementaires d'être nombre de nos
clubs se soient les sujets c'est de
pouvoir bénéficier de l'organisation de
rencontres de petits déjeuners de petits
déjeuners de déjeuner ou dîner au gré
des rendez-vous les groupes d'influencé
tentent de tourner la loi à leur
avantage
et là encore des propositions
d'amendements peuvent circuler ce du
lobby totalement décomplexée mais c'est
une lubie totalement transparent dans sa
structuration de la façon dont la pensée
est on l'a voulu et c'est pour ça que
des parlementaires comptent accepte d'y
venir où on est accepté d co présidence
c'est qu'en effet on peut pas faire plus
transparent que notre modèle
pourtant ces clubs qui n'ont aucune
existence officielle au parlement ne
sont soumis à aucun encadrement aucun
contrôle certains ont des budgets
importants jusqu'à 400 mille euros se
pose alors la question du financement
le club de la table française a par
exemple pour partenaires et financeurs
la fédération qui représente la
charcuterie et son industrie ainsi que
la fédération française des spiritueux
il est important que le club ne laisse
pas entendre qu'il s'agit d'une
émanation de l'institution publique la
transparence elle viendra de la
publicité qui est donné l'identité des
organisateurs quand on sait qu'ils
financent tel ou tel événement c'est
assez facile rendre compte de leurs
activités afin d'éviter tout conflit
d'intérêts c'est la demande de la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique
suite à une étude sur ces clubs
un travail de l'ombre encore tabou alors
que la pratique s'est professionnalisé
depuis les années 90 le nombre de
cabinets de lobbying a été multipliée
par cinq
c'est la course était bonne
très franchement pour voir ce qu'on peut
faire ensemble notamment sur le maroc
est sur l'afrique intervient par la
suite une profession qui s'est amélioré
à une époque tout le monde se déclarer
lobbies parce qu'il avait trop copains
de politique donc tout le monde faisait
du lobby on s'est aperçu qu'il suffisait
pas d'avoir des amis et cardet de bresse
c'était aussi un métier de guide de
droit bonne connaissance la matière
législative c'est un métier de
communication c'est un métier économique
l'enjeu pour le lobbyiste c'est d'être
apporteur de solutions anticiper les
besoins de ses clients
là on a un véritable rôle c'est de nous
mêmes éduquer nos propres clients les
entreprises privées à faire de la
prévention
trop souvent on vient nous voir parce
que un amendement est passé et empêche
demain une industrie d'exister j'ai
presque envie à c'est trop tard donc le
bing c'est aussi d'être en situation de
prévention de regarder au sein de 2 la
veille là par contre législatif quels
sont les alertes une question posée à
l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat
ta travail permanent l'ensemble des
lobbies de veille de pro activité très
en amont de l'évolution législative pour
dire et lancé des alertes
attention alerte il ya un député qui
commence à gratouiller sur vos métiers
parmi ses clients figurent en majorité
des entreprises privées car les
lobbystes interviennent surtout pour les
groupes industriels et financiers
10% seulement représentent les ong dans
certaines entreprises le lobbying se
fait en interne directement les
spécialistes de l' influence occupe dans
les organigrammes un poste stratégique
directeur des affaires publiques à
pernod ricard ce poste existe depuis
près de 20 ans et garantit un meilleur
retour sur investissement pour
l'entreprise bac
sur le bureau de laurent scheer les
contacts d'autres groupes d'intérêts
influent notamment la carte de visite de
vin et société
le lobby viticole pour être efficace il
faut aussi savoir ce que défendent les
autres dans le coeur n'est pas fille à
vin et société directement mais comme en
premier lieu en france des
problématiques sont tes productions
peuvent être similaires
on a des échanges partie du métier c'est
aussi d'aller voir quels sont tous les
gens intéressés de manière à avoir des
messages cohérents et convergentes
une façon alors d'élargir son influence
et de peser davantage sur le travail
législatif
les lobbys sont partout et pourtant les
règlements qu pour les encadrer
ce n'est que depuis 2009 que le
parlement demande au lobby de
s'enregistrer et de se soumettre un code
de bonne conduite au sénat s'inscrire
sur le registre est obligatoire pour
obtenir un badge d'accès mais il figure
à peine 150 professionnels de l'
influence
c'est peu car le registre n'est soumis à
aucun contrôle
la maison le président de l'association
sherpa a rendez-vous ce jour-là au sénat
pour défendre ses propositions sur
l'encadrement des lobbys du côté
transparence je pense que ben voilà
certainement qu il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire puis on s'éloigne de
l'intérêt général plus le lobby est
cachée de il utilise des chemins de
france moi il va se précipiter parce que
enregistrés sur les registres y avait eu
au moment du scandale les médiateurs ou
de vote à certains de loi s'il y avait
eu elles projettent de lobbying
obligatoire universel pour sexualité
aussi commode pour un symptôme de lobby
d'agir comme ils l'ont fait pour essayer
d'éteindre les conséquences de ce
scandale encadrer de façon plus stricte
les lobbys c'est une des mesures phares
de la loi sapin 2 sur la transparence de
la vie économique
la france a du retard en la matière pour
la première fois une loi introduit le
terme lobbying elles prévoient un
registre obligatoire des groupes d'
influence publiques et consultables sur
internet et pour la première fois le
registre intègre les membres du
gouvernement et les cabinets
ministériels ce que la loi va créer
c'est un premier registre un premier
outil d'encadrement des échanges donc un
peu plus de transparence sur qui sont
les représentants d'intérêts quelles
sont leurs activités et quels sont les
budgets qu'ils y consacrent
après il ya la question de la
traçabilité de la décision publique la
transparence dont une entre ces échanges
c'est à dire quelles sont les positions
qui sont transmises les notes de
position les amendements etc qui sont
transmises aux décideurs publics et
quels sont les rendez-vous qui sont pris
entre les lobbys et les décideurs
publics et là dessus on n'a pas encore
d'éléments qui sont prévus dans le
projet de loi la loi sapin de et bien un
premier pas mais sans un encadrement des
échanges entre ceux qui font la loi et
les lobbys le registre obligatoire seule
permettra t'il vraiment d'éviter les
dérives
en